I loved the Philippines when I was there
though no you didn't were there for four
days no I was there for weeks
maybe you weren't sweetie
well we spent how long in the hospital
okay we arrived in Cebu yeah that night
after 24 hours I got sick okay I spent
five days in the hospital
I flew back I'll go but that 24 hours
and we were there I remember every
single moment of it though yeah we land
we went a little cafe at that Airport
and then people are dancing in those
dresses remember they were dancing you
got there because it was we had seen
Oleg which is our yearly festival then
we went to the hotel then we had Italian
food at that Italian restaurant remember
yeah and that I can visually reven
remember what everything looks like yeah
and then that night I was dancing to
Depeche Mode yeah everything counts
yeah we do we a lot we
a lot oh wow and then I had a
heart attack my sleep that was like the
most shocking thing yeah I can't breathe
and now what do you do it's like you're
calling the front desk we don't have a
there's no ambulance yeah what the
and then you call the the cab comes we
put her in the cab will you drive to
this green building that has no hospital
sign oh my god you're in there and then
all of a sudden she goes water water I
don't want to relive it the last thing I
want to said okay get me water and I go
get her water we know how you got to pay
for it oh my god all right here's money
no you got to go across the street so I
had to run across the street wait in
line to get her water when she was about
to die it was the worst anyway I'm sorry
for bringing it up but yeah but the
Philippines is a beautiful place the
24-hour 24 hours Oasis amazing I
remember every detail I dancing in the
lobby I remember that
yeah it was great and I love your people
don't say that your people sounds weird
what why is it people we are we really
are and that's the
[Music]